and you know they say that we can't
judge and we can't say anything but and
I I actually don't have a problem if
it's not hurting anybody you know
honestly if if a woman is not in debt
okay because debt everyone else has to
pay for if a woman's not overweight in
the Health Care System doesn't have to
pay for her as a plan for retirement and
she wants to go be crazy with no kids I
don't care but the problem is we have a
bunch of women that make everybody pay
for their bad decisions they don't have
anything planned for retirement they're
in a lot of debt when they have kids
they don't raise them they make someone
else raise them someone else do it and
who has to suffer it's either the kids
the taxpayers or the men like if you
want to be miserable in your own
decisions I don't care but don't make
someone else pay for it